you will need to be there broadcasting
your updates what you need to be doing
is being there engaging in the
conversation facilitating them talking
to each other about your your artwork I
mean is that right you recommend that
right that's what i recommend yeah i
mean the word amount sometimes the only
goes so far people like well because i
recommended it it automatically turns
into a by and that's not true I mean
sometimes you want to hear it from a
couple other people sometimes what one
person likes you're not particularly a
fan of that thing um so I like the idea
of using social media really is building
an audience around yourself as an artist
and then you will have to spend less
time broadcasting out your message
because you will feed just then and they
will be so excited and enthusiastic
about what you do that they will want to
tell people you're not telling generally
you need to go out and get five more
people throwing my page did you know
they want to do it because it's more fun
to have more people that they know or
people that they could get to know who
also like the same things that they're
interested in and that's what you do
with those pages as you give them a
reason to want to do that by giving them
exclusive content or giving them
exclusive access to you and giving them
things you know would help them so if
you know what they're interested in you
be like you said the connector between
that other thing and then inadvertently
it brings it back to you but you don't
have to tell them to do that they don't
want to do it they will go out of their
way right for you right if you can do
with this content will do this to write
record labels will do this you know if
you think about if you think about music
blogs there's a really great music blog
here in la called aquarium drunkard
according to driver calm you should it's
fantastic if you like sort of americana
music right well busy what he's doing
all day is managing my attention right I
I like this kind of music so instead of
having to go out myself and search
forward and look by genre and look go to
major outlets and find the little tiny
pieces that are like it so I can just go
to aquarium record where every day he's
got something new
for me I can I can discover new things
right so he's managed the process of
discovery for me right that's social
media to write with that what that is is
is trust a trusted source recommending
content right so the aquarium drunkard
actually doesn't have a you know a
financial interest in me going off to
buy those Stevie Wonder reissues right
but what they did was put a bunch of
context and helped me discover that
there were Stevie Wonder reissues to buy
right so I bought them because I
discovered them and got some great
context than a review and some
commentary from the blog as the person
who's you know as the business who is
releasing those cv12 reissues it's my
job to make sure that I've got a
relationship with aquarium drunkard
because they manage a lot of people's
attention and I can very scalable and
quickly give them pieces of content let
them do their thing around it and they
can present it to their audience right
the same thing will happen in any
creative industry right we just don't in
as people as consumers we just don't
consume what's marketed to us as much as
we use to write 20 years ago the
creative industries were all about
control of production control of
distribution and control of marketing
right those three things were basically
controlled by the by the incumbent
industry so if you wanted to make
something you had to do it in this way
with this equipment with the this
financial structure right things like
pro tools and and the you know the
silicon you know it's like a revolution
with with small handheld you know flip
cameras like we're making this
commentary on I'll just destroy that
right production is basically ubiquitous
and free right for 150 bucks we can buy
a flip cam we can make whole film and
then you know distribution right so the
web comes along and one of the things
the web goes really well amongst a lot
of things is make distribution
ubiquitous and free right we're going to
finish this interview we're going to
have this clip posted on YouTube we have
YouTube player embedded on the film
courage blog distribution anybody in the
world who wants to see that can see it
right there isn't a single person out
there that they can't have access to
that okay marketing suddenly though gets
really hard right because all these
people are making content that was
previously you know hard to do lots of
people are distributing content
everywhere so I go to youtube and I've
got
millions and billions of videos to watch
if I go kind of iTunes or Amazon there's
hundreds of thousands of millions of
albums to listen to right as a consumer
I'm suddenly now faced with sort of
overwhelming choice right so how do I
window that down well that in that video
as a marketer that makes your marketing
task really hard drive your marketing
costs way up because you used to spend
100 grand and you get 50,000 people and
I spend a hundred grand and you get
5,000 people right like the amount of
money it takes to fall up large enough
audiences to make an interesting
business around a piece of content is
getting its getting more and more and
more expensive or harder and harder so
if you're not taking advantage of the
web inherently with what it's really
good at which is empowering the four of
us to find each other talk about
something that we care about right very
efficiently super easy right quick quick
message on Twitter great lots of people
saw it they know we're going to have the
interview they were they were they were
listening on live online sending us
sending us questions right super
efficient didn't have to have an
employee didn't have to have expensive
phone system didn't have time in college
again didn't buy any ads right so the
same thing applies to getting the word
out about you were created for when you
create a piece of art okay how do I make
sure that when I release this thing I do
it in a way that people who will like it
are empowered to share it as much as
possible right that's your sort of
that's your sort of job as a marketer
first and foremost is to not
inadvertently prevent a great word of
mouth response or a great viral response
by not using common existing tools
Facebook Twitter right you don't have to
do all those things but you need to be
realistic about that's where people are
and that's where folks are to have it in
that discovery process so it's not a
check box it's something to have
strategy for but so the answer is yes
the accommodate to spend that time yeah
using social media especially I'm
starting brand new right yes for sure
just even if even if you're an
established person like you said you
can't advertise your way into
you going to have to empower the people
who are your fans and get and they're
going to want to pass the word round all
you have to do is give them a way to do
it well that's your job you know
facilitate that's your job well I'm make
it really amazing oh yes that's i would
like to say that's a given but yes you
do have to have something sexual oh no
I'm take rule number one don't suck
Oh